hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
and this is Tamra just saw and today I'm
gonna be talking about bird box the
Netflix meme sensation I watched the
movie last night and before watching it
I heard so many extremes about what
people thought about this film it was
crazy
regardless of if it turned out to be
good or bad for me I was just impressed
that I was hearing so much about it so
if you're hearing crap about it you're
still hearing about it
Netflix is incredible at getting their
stuff seen I'm such a Netflix fangirl if
you will I think that they do such a
good job with their content most of the
time with getting things out there
marketing most of the time I heard a
rumor that a lot of big-name actors were
turning things down movies and TV shows
down because they were waiting on a
Netflix contract and that's significant
that is a really crazy shift in actors
work actors jobs actors priorities
that's crazy this star Sandra Bullock
and trivanti Rhodes both who I really
really love moonlight is in my top three
favorite films of all time and Miss
Congeniality is a god damn it also has a
lot of other people in it Sarah Paulson
from American Horror Story which I love
Danielle MacDonald who I just watched
for the first time in dumplin and really
enjoyed that movie I will get into the
acting of this film in a bit but she was
incredible in that it was a pleasant
surprise to see here in this again John
Malkovich and others
real quick before I get into my thoughts
about it I wanted to bring up a few
points about a lot of the negativity
it's getting this movie is about a
biological warfare monster
looking dude you don't actually see him
but you imagine him to look like Cthulhu
and it's going around and killing you or
making you kill yourself if you see it
since the blindfold you saw the
thumbnail you get it a lot of people are
saying it's very reminiscent of a quiet
place but with seeing instead of noises
or it's like exact plot of the happening
which true though bird box is based on a
book and the book was written before
either of those movies were ever made so
there's that knocked down it is so
interesting though to see another movie
made about something that we've already
seen a bunch of times so you could argue
yeah shouldn't a book was done before
but why do we need another movie about
these things which is fair and it comes
down to the fact that it's only worth it
if the movie is good I think the movie
is neither of the extremes I think it's
it's it's got some merit for sure
there's some really cool things being
done overall it just feels like it's
really been done before I think it's
about 30 40 minutes too long and what I
got out of it is that Sandra Bullock is
in like a career high with her acting
chops like she just took everything she
could with this I think weirdly paced
script screenplay another thing I think
that's difficult is I could not connect
with any of these characters because the
movie opens and you see Sandra Bullock's
character Mallory rowing a boat on the
river with two children you get the
sense that that's we're headed towards
that that's not like the start of the
movie and then you know we get to meet
all these lovable characters oh you get
this this is the end of the film and
we're all we're gonna keep jumping back
to her on the boat what you do which I
really enjoy those parts but that means
that you're probably not gonna have the
rest of the people I got the sense from
the very first shot of the movie that
those were our core three people and
that everyone else was probably going to
die because this is the end of the world
scenario movie and I had a really hard
time connecting with all of the
characters except for javante Rhodes him
and Sandra had amazing chemistry and I
wish he spoilers I wish he wouldn't die
also I had a hard time connecting with
people because it was that just movie
cliche of all of these people this group
of random strangers all get together and
now they're living in this home it's the
end of the world we seen this before in
movies like it comes at night where
people gather together and they don't
want to be together but they have to be
together and the miss there was a lot of
pullings from the mist as well a lot of
movies that this movie pulled from and
the question still remains is this a
better movie than those movies
I think the mist is fun enough I think
that happening is a garbage train wreck
no I think a quiet place is really good
and also has some flaws and I think this
is definitely worthy of people's time
and absolutely has flaws again I just
keep coming back to Sandra Bullock was
just Wow in this she was so good the
rest of the characters though were not
likable not enjoyable the character
Danielle McDonald plays Olympia is so
unlikable she calls herself spoiled and
so that's just kind of what I took and I
ran with that feeling for that character
I'm pretty sure we're supposed to love
her I also think that her cuteness and
her acting style and acting choices
really worked in dumplin I don't think
they carry over into this I think a lot
of the acting Styles just clashed
tremendously in this movie
Milton Howry from get out please pretty
much it's very similar character is he
doesn't get out and he's just so great
and get out and then this it the tone of
it just like really clashes with
everyone cuz it's a very serious thing
and there's like a want to be funny with
his character and it doesn't pull
through is funny and so it's just kind
of like really clashing John Malkovich
is
oh my god he's hilariously terrible in
this movie Doug and Rob Walker are
always pretty hard on John Malkovich or
at least lovingly make fun of him and
his acting style and I don't know that
I've ever I don't even know if I've seen
him in anything I probably have I listen
who knows but this everything that he
did in this movie I was like oh my god
Doug and Rob are so correct and then I
will say that some of the deaths look a
little cheesy to me the first death we
see is this woman in a hospital hitting
her head against glass it looks cheesy
she's not really doing the motion hard
enough for it to clack-clack pretty crap
it's glass cracking glass together clack
I'm just you know trying to speed up the
whole video for you guys anyways for to
crack this glass window that's gotta be
it's a thick hospital window I don't
imagine it's very thin glass and she's
just kind of bunking in her head and so
it looks cheesy when her first crash
against it just shatters the glass
there's blood everywhere it's kind of
final destination some of the deaths
look really good and some of them don't
look really good and I imagine that's
just because there's a lot of deaths
happening that they didn't you know
spend a million years on all of them
it's a mistake I think I think that I
don't know they it made it less
effective but the things that really
really really worked well for me were
the suspenseful moments that they did
incredibly well there's a scene that
takes place in a car they're driving to
go get groceries at a grocery store
because they can't look they black out
the windows and they're driving and
they're using GPS and a proximity sensor
on the car and you got to suspend some
disbelief but I love it I think it's
really well done it's very suspenseful
it's thrilling they make it there and
then that whole scene is very
suspenseful and thrilling I just wrote
wall at the local grocery store having
six industrial walkie-talkies just out
at the front
No some of the scenes are really good
we're in most of the movie you don't get
that great of character development
there's one scene where Mallory and Tom
and the two kids are looking for
groceries and Valerie finds a box of
strawberry pop-tarts and there's one
little thing sleeve of pop-tarts and she
breaks both of them in half and they
each get 1/4 of a pop-tart or half of a
pop-tart and she's like this is what
strawberry tastes like because the kids
have never had strawberry before and
then they just sit there kind of
giggling and in quiet with each other
and they're just taking this moment in
and then they hear cars come up and it's
those crazy people who can see and
they're trying to get kill them so it's
a really good moment it's suspenseful
it's sweet you get a sense of who they
are and then there's just a weird scenes
where john mcafee story gradient I just
it's so weird in that scene that's when
Tom dies and Mallory is left with the
two children and then you're just on the
river for the rest of it and it's so
suspenseful on the river at this moment
I don't care that it's very similar to a
lot of films because it's very intense
it's keeping my attention I will say
that a lot of the movie didn't keep my
it just moved a little too slow for me
in some parts it's like 69% I don't mean
well nice its 69% but get my real
attention and then the rest was just
kind of like okay it's not I'm not
upsetting it but it's just a little slow
moving they make it to where they've
been traveling this whole time on the
river which is a compound where they
heard there was safety and you find out
that it is a school for they blind and I
was wondering when they were going to
address that like there's a big huge
amount of people here that we are not
addressing I feel like that was way
underutilized I feel like one of the
characters would have definitely
mentioned that by now but it made the
reveal of it being a school for the
blind a lot better there's no resolution
there's no fix for the future but for
the moment they're safe and it felt like
a good ending to me there's some total
weird holes and
miss steps in this film but overall I
still found a merit and I still really
liked it the biggest thing I took away
from it is that Sandra Bullock rules
there's a monologue in this movie the
kids have been separated from her and
she's trying to get them back and the
boy reveals that the girl is scared and
so she makes this plea to the girl and
it is worth sitting through the movie
just to see that monologue it is so damn
good thank you so much for watching I
will see you all next week
with another movie
[Music]